devant la caméra interview et interviews
enjoy
la précision au tir au pistolet
[Musique]
et s'est placé à peu près nos
personnages parfaitement sur les tiers
très bien avec l'intersection sur la
tête royal
cela ressemble à un cours de dieu visuel
et cela tombe bien car sans d'état en
revanche il prend un caractère
particulier il s'agit de prémices d'une
vraie formation de jeunes reporters
initiée par l'urss
l'union nationale du sport scolaire elle
s'appuie sur les associations sportives
des collèges et des lycées pour former
de futurs communicant qu'on a lancé le
projet jeune reporter à l'association
sportive pour remplacer l'excité basket
qui n'était plus possible au regard du
contexte
donc on a démarché des jeunes dans la
cour du collège qui ne connaissez pas
cette activité et c'est les jeunes qui
sont amenés ensuite à filmer les
activités qu'on peut maintenir dans le
cadre de cette association et on espère
ces jeunes-là poursuivront au fil des
années cette activité ça permet aussi de
maintenir autre chose une petite dizaine
d'élèves a suivi une initiation
essentiellement théorique au rythme
d'une heure par semaine d'octobre à
février
en complément est associée à dix autres
élèves s'intéresser ils bénéficient
d'une journée entière de formation
encadrée par un vrai journaliste
l'objectif étant déguisé le regard
critique de ces ados lice l'idée c'est
que quand les élèves un ressort de la
formation il est compris comment sont
conçus les reportages ou quand il
regarda reportage télé demain et
puissent le regarder avec un autre
regard un peu plus actif et que du coup
ils soient un peu plus conscients de ce
qu'ils voient aussi à l'image après si à
certains ça donne des idées de location
c'est génial aussi le départ aux plots
jaunes la zone de relais entre les deux
plots bleu pour la pratique rien de
mieux qu'un cours d'éducation physique
en plein air aujourd'hui c'est laser run
l'équivalent du biathlon sans neige
nice qui s'est surtout on allume son
micro les jeunes reporters ont un peu de
mal avec le matériel mais l'
enthousiasme compense les failles et les
organisateurs de l'opération voit déjà
les bénéfices à courte et longue
échéance de ces ateliers
à l'une et c'est ce sont deux finalités
à la fois une une finalité sportive
puisque on veut que les élèves
enfin faire pratiquer le plus possible
de l'activité physique aux jeunes et on
a également une activité qui firent et
citoyen pour essayer de former envers
les bénévoles de demain lui est né ça se
forme aussi de jeunes arbitres de jeunes
dirigeants des petits entraîneurs et
même des interprètes eux ne deviendront
pas tout journaliste mais leur quotidien
est déjà envahi par les images et
l'univers audiovisuel les facile et fo
avec mes copines ou métiers de la
musique et ont filmé pour voir si ça
faisait des choses jolies et j'aime bien
faire des montages vidéos des photos mon
frère lui il aime bien puisque c'est lui
par exemple qui prend les photos en
vacances avec son appareil photo
ce sera mon tour maintenant